[Musique]
bonsoir les petits amis au soir je suis
assez fâché ce soir mon petit doigt m'a
dit qu'il y à beaucoup d'enfants qui
vont se coucher avec les mains sales
avec le morceau we nounours et sans se
laver les dents
son seul a vu le temps où ce pur
possible que trop se sont sûrement pas
du collant et pas preneur j'espère bien
mon échelle je m'en vais voir ça de plus
près c'est que moi je ne vais pas chez
des enfants qui ne se lave pas les dents
et hop hop hop à proprement pour
maman elle a dit que si tu arrives pas
tu adores ce soir tu vas laval est cette
nuit
moi je ne fais pas je vois que ses
enfants sont sages ils font leur poids
le bruce
waouh ça me prenait la même temps qui
s'en va
je pense qu'il bouge aïe aïe aïe j'ai
peur peur mais qu'est ce que cela veut
dire
on n'a pas peur parce qu'on a eu le
temps qui bouge voilà aussi aux non on
est bien content au pontet
quand on a eu le temps qui bouge on tire
sur lathan dean elle tombe et après une
belle dans toute neuve repousse une dent
très solide qui peut croquer des tas de
bonnes choses alors viens pimprenelle
tiens tu attache la ficelle et moi je
dire ah non tu te rends compte même le
monde qui fait il veut ma tâche et la
dent écrit sait pas quels procédés pas à
[Musique]
non pour qu'une tâche bobo au tueur on
tient à ce que j'ai pleuré les filles
fernand gardes tu attends pas preneur la
petite souris ne viendra pas c'est tout
la petite chérie ça ne sert qu'un bonne
nuit
ça la petite souris pourquoi la petite
souris aux alentours et à la petite
souris c'est une gentille petite souris
qui pose une belle pièce en argent tout
neuf
là où elle trouve une tandis de 1
annonce enlèvement quinzaine t'adore
voyons montre moi ce mouchoir pape rhône
elle est le très joli dit or et regarde
un peu le plafond de quelle couleur
willer
et voilà les matins l'avouer elle est
très mignonne à la vigne en bandits
c'était bien tu sais qu'il faut la
mettre pour clavier souris elle passe
oui je connais un endroit où la petite
souris passera sûrement
allez vite vous coucher je m'en vais la
tâche et kesha qu'elle vient d'un seul
mot sur le 2 1 et maria küng à pourvoir
il faut attendre qu'elle tombe tout seul
nicolas bonne nuit les enfants vers mes
vitres au joli teint
bonne nuit des noces à demain mais
nicolas venu qu'au premier bonne nuit
les enfants embrassé au fola là que se
passe-t-il au roubaix mais qui est ce
qui me chatouille les pieds se boit trop
je ne cache que le cochon ça ne m'étonne
pas de toi je te trouve bien cachottier
ces temps ci je suis mr le poteau on y
vend motors de 2,3 au bond et bien en
route mon cher nounours bonne nuit les
enfants à demain dogon
[Musique]
oh